hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba and
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch from
one of my favorite channels today looper
predicting the biggest box-office bombs
of 2019 but we're gonna have to hold the
phone on that reaction for just a second
here folks because I am excited to shout
out today's video sponsor which is skin
it skin it is awesome what these guys do
is they make incredible premium vinyl
decal skins for your PlayStation your
Xbox your Nintendo systems plus they got
stuff for your phone too if you've got
an iPhone and LG a pixel of galaxy they
have a variety of different cases
including waterproof ones but the best
part is they offer cases and skins in a
plethora of different designs so I'm
holding in my hat thank you Tyler a guy
got this PlayStation 4 oh boy very
recently this is the example of what the
bottom of a ps4 pro looks like but look
what it is the new skin it Batman logo
people let's like this and if you're
gaming in the Stone Age like me you can
even get one for your Xbox 360 oh yeah
or your ps3 or you know we what have you
mm-hmm
John shown the lapto yeah this one I'm
very much excited for it oh yeah look
out I have never wanted to go on
Facebook more people who know that I've
never wanted to get on the computer to
stare at the back of the screen more and
I also case only John got it a little
spider guy a little waterproof I'm gonna
get one for me and I really could have
done more I'm sorry so you can customize
your phone or consult with officially
licensed brands such as Marvel DC Disney
Sanrio which is my favorite company oh
and more and you know what else they
allow you to do your own custom designs
as well custom skins custom cases from
your very own uploaded designs so guys
if you need a little extra protection
for that phone or console of yours or
you just want to add a new splash of
style head on over to skinny calm and be
sure to use our promo code real rejects
Oh
word and you'll save yourself 20% off
your 20% I just got a message for the
folks at skin it and they're gonna bump
that promo code up to 25% so enjoy I
think John owes me a phone case now with
that real rechecks promo code amen
christmas is coming
thank you skin it this is all sinks guys
really cool I'm gonna get more just hug
this all video it's often hard to tell
which movies will be big hits and which
ones are destined to flop but the 2019
film calendar has another I was a catch
wasn't any of these films making money
get ready for a sneak peek at the
biggest box-office bombs of 2019
serenity certainly has a lot going for
it it stars a list Academy Award winners
Matthew McConaughey and Anne Hathaway on
screen together for the first time since
interstellar but even their beautiful
multi-million dollar bumps are no
guarantee you'll make that sure
McConaughey has evolved from his rom-com
and MTV phase but the Makana sense is
still been spotty at the box office
unfortunately serenity will most likely
continue this trend mostly because the
movie looks well indescribable weird
movies are fine but they don't lead to
box office Florida and serenity doesn't
just look bizarre it looks baffling the
trailer is defy comprehension and
consequently nobody can tell what it is
about movie goers want to have at least
some idea what they're spending their
bucks on don't January 25th it probably
won't be serenity on the plus side it's
combination that Betty Kim seems brand
light but it's also going up against the
second weekend of him nights on a lots
much in system that's gonna fall
as mainstream before being stuck job on
strange material let's know no matter
how much fun with some serenity off okay
it's a better record Oh terminating it
and avatar 4 james cameron is producing
alina battle angel along gestating
sci-fi adventure based on famous poster
I'm really worried this is creator
Robert Rodriguez who's helping the 200
million dollar film adaptation if you're
getting a Last Airbender or ghost in the
shell live from the trailers you're not
alone Airbender made money goes not so
much Malita seems more like the latter
with its pg-13 rating likely to turn off
fans with a violent source material
while doing nothing to lure in the
kiddos
there's also Rodriguez whose last film
was 2014's mega Turkey sin city a dame
to kill for damage the glass development
aureus for stretching a dollar he made
his first movie el Mariachi for just
seven thousand dollars but this movie's
budget is about twenty eight thousand
times that it's WagonR your movie to
make money because it was so cheap James
Lazar you can look for this to bomb
stateside when it hits theaters really
fourteen hoping it'll perform well
overseas and if not at least James
Cameron has his for Avatar sequels to
look forward to
so the state looks tremendous clever
concept compelling visuals John Goodman
Vera Farmiga any one of those is enough
to earn our money even so it may not be
enough to make this blend of this ice
good action in it that's for sure gonna
block an active state was bumped from
August 2018 back to March 29 2019 where
it will go up directly against Tim
Burton's Dumbo the first a minute
excuse planet I've had everybody put it
for Rupert Wyatt
but high-concept sci-fi is hit or miss
for every district 9 or 10 o'clock were
filled Lane there's Jupiter ascending or
city of a thousand planets sci-fi is a
risky Babel flying elephant that's tough
the captive state may have a chance of
counter programming but only if it's
really good we've all been burned by
incredible trailers for bland movies
so hopefully captives they won't follow
that trend few weeks be aware of austere
beige movies that come out in the spring
that's a general haha sometimes and
usually starts in the fall
with the notable exception of Best
Picture winner crash springtime message
movies rarely make a dent in the public
consciousness let alone my sauce take
the best of enemies for example slated
for an April 5th release the film is
about a civil rights activist played by
taraji P Henson who co-chairs a
community meeting about school
segregation with a taking a penny leader
played by Sam Rockwell he's playing
another race experience changes both of
their lives it sounds like either a
really saccharine made-for-tv movie or a
really twisted SNL skit but it's
actually based on a true story
instant recently started a company
didn't love hesitating figures as well
as the award-winning hit TV show Empire
Rockwell meanwhile recently snagged an
Oscar for his supporting role in three
billboards outside heavy Missouri and
has consistently proven himself a
versatile character actor
a fighting chance at the box office but
more likely the best of enemies will
disappear from theaters just as fast as
every other awards contender released in
April the New Mutants is about a group
of teenage mutant superhero are on
Turtles so that's already a huge mark
against it none helping matters is the
confused genre splicing of horror and
superhero action in what will be the
13th film and 20th Century Fox's x-men
franchise take a moment to consider how
much of your life you've spent watching
x-men movies to its credit the series
hasn't been overly cautious about mixing
genres the comedy superhero hybrid
Deadpool spin-offs have made millions of
the domestic box office and are the
highest grossing films in the entire
x-men franchise but those films has been
raising people actually wanted to see
them join us what are the reception for
the three people excited for david ige a
dark murky was read until trailer even
has some fans mockingly saying it looks
like a DC EU movie which are fighting
words in the superhero genre is there
really an appetite for a hostile
x-men yes bad bland just plain bizarre
choices has damaged the fresh princess
Bank ability and perhaps more
importantly his credibility which brings
us to Gemini man which is being held by
angry more importantly at reunite Smith
with his bad boys an enemy of the state
producer Jerry Bruckheimer back up put
the gun down the story and all their
hitman faces off against a young clone
of themselves sounds like a lazy goober
ripoff except Gemini man was in
development for 20 years before being
greenlit Wow
it certainly feels like a movie that
would have been fresh in this will be
good I trusted you wait it'll make money
or whatever mom it did Terminator
Genisys was a dud in 2015 in the u.s.
anyway it made enough overseas to
justify another trip to the post
apocalypse every new Terminator movie is
basically another attempt to resurrect
an aimless prince hi honest have fate
interesting this year
see there's forty eight hundred back in
time and stop these movies from being
made and that's exactly what it sounds
like it's going to happen t6 is supposed
to be a direct sequel to t2 rise of
machines salvation Genesis in the Sarah
Connor Chronicles wiped from history you
can do that with a time travel movie
right not her Sarah Connor Chronicles or
a Connor the James Cameron who is
producing and contributing to the story
that's good enough for a little interest
and hopefully it'll be enough to save
the film from bombing harder than
Judgment Day
I like list videos jokes
that's what's like when films takes very
musical adaptation they are doing
capsules sure Chicago did pretty well
financially but he can't say the same
for Rock of Ages were rent and while
Andrew Lloyd Webber's Mary Poppins
returns greatest showmen yearly stays
Mia it's based on one of his most
popular musicals and features perhaps
his most famous song memory how
for his most popular musical in Broadway
strongest running show was the Phantom
of the Opera which only scared off 51
million dollars in change in the US
theaters on the fact it's coming out on
December 20th 2019 the same day as a
quiet little indie drama currently known
as Star Wars Episode nine with that kind
of bugs on competition chances are slim
that crowds will show up to watch a
bunch of dancing cats that mean the
greatest showman did pretty well the
greatest showman did do pretty well and
cats is a classic cats is a classic it's
also kind of a theater meme got a
disagree with cat all right after that
I'm disagree with cats if there's
something that this past December has
shown which was a very overstuffed month
is that there's certain types of movies
that will just do well if it gets decent
enough reviews well yeah fifty to sixty
percent at least and was this footage
they're showing from an actual train for
this guy sure it's gonna be Star Wars no
but the thing that a lot of people don't
keep in mind when it comes to these
movies is a week's it'll run sure and if
it's gonna run for a while and musicals
December time no one thought greatest
showman would be a big hit and it was
but it did terrible its first weekend or
mediocre and and then over time it
became this sensation well hey I feel
like musicals usually have that chance
like the big talk of December this one
has been Aquaman but you know what
bumblebee is making money Mary Poppins
Returns is making money into the spider
movies making money that Nicole's be
making money those weeks leaked into
January which is usually a dud month so
you know then you need something more
for the families and then whoever's not
gonna be only gonna take it for Star
Wars that day he's gonna go watch cats
I feel like cats could have some legs
just cuz there's so many factors that
you know cats cats have legs every movie
Greg could you milk me I feel like cats
can have some legs just because there's
so many angles that you can approach
that from because you can have like the
morbid curiosity angle you can have the
like I'll go see anything Broadway angle
you'll have the people who just don't
want to go see the angle like I feel
like that one and terminator will have
legs of some kind
like I don't think terminator will be a
flop I will go to bat for everything
I've heard about Terminator 6 like their
pre promo and pre height that they've
been doing I've been more than excited
for it it's not even with like these
nostalgia glasses that I have on oh
Linda Hamilton's returning and Arnold
Schwarzenegger is back in it too I'm
excited for that but I'm not like that's
what sold me on this movie it was that
45-minute interview they did with like
when they get asked a question it's not
these vague answers they really are
thinking this through and I trust them
if it's bad I'll admit it
I've been let down before a minute it I
just think it's gonna be a nice
everyone's just comparing this because
of the franchise been going downhill
Genesis was terrible and now everyone's
just it's gonna suck you know it's gonna
suck there's no room left for it but I I
just don't think this one will be like
the last few installments I feel like
it'll be different and I definitely
trust who is behind it I think for me
what got me optimistic was the
combination of that discussion with the
vote of confidence that Linda Hamilton
signing on brought to me because James
Cameron kind of took some of the weight
of his name off when he was like Genesis
great people gonna love it the new film
which in my mind I think of as the third
film I'm cautiously optimistic about
that movie I feel like it'll definitely
at least be better than the last several
but either way I just don't think it'll
be a flop I just don't I think there's a
lot of curiosity on this one Hamilton
you had Halloween with Jamie Lee Curtis
like even the hate that it's getting I
think there's still anticipation even
from the haters who don't want to admit
that they kind of want to be yeah
because whose involvement you go yeah
exactly these I have a V I have some
faith in it Gemini man I'm wondering why
they're saying this would be a flock
just because it's a familiar plot to
something like looper or something like
that I mean you got a li behind the
camera Will Smith leading it and Jerry
Bruckheimer producing to me that sounds
like it's probably yes time it's hard
for me to imagine that this wouldn't be
something all that interesting there was
I am Legend with
Will Smith and he was the only popular
thing from that movie yeah that was like
more than a decade ago at this point or
about a decade ago I forget sure Will
Smith has made some pretty off choices
look when you hear that one it's like a
blockbuster after earth was the only
blockbuster film he did and that wasn't
even like a typical Will Smith
blockbuster you know I think when you do
Will Smith blockbuster you're gonna get
a blockbuster that's the way it works
yeah he's only had one major flop and
that was after earth sure he's done
collateral beauty he's done seven pounds
he's in his weird flicks he's playing
the genie but I think I feel like Gemini
Man's another one that'll be huge or at
least they'll make its money I can see
the potential for it performing III
that's a weird mixture because yeah Will
Smith at the megaplex is a bit of a
contentious thing where it didn't used
to be and then like Angley I don't know
where his clout is at anymore
the familiar concept I wonder how people
will take that cuz like for me I would
probably see this and go oh it's a lot
like looper looper wasn't like the
biggest film so I don't think like the
similarity will hurt its chance of no no
no definitely not
New Mutants I am genuinely concerned
about I don't sit in the corner thinking
it's gonna be terrible or honest in the
corner so that it's gonna be good I have
a lot of hope that it will be good and
my feelings primarily reside there I
feel like most of the x-men movies are
pretty damn good films and I like the
first trailer I didn't know what got all
this criticism at first because I
genuinely liked it the idea of going
horror and having some like supernatural
horror than some body horror elements to
it that like that excites me I think
they can pull it off I feel like they
can if josh trank was right well that's
the thing as long as it doesn't come out
like a Frankenstein's monster because I
just don't know what to expect from that
movie it sounds like you know in the
past years we have had all this talk of
like what re shoots mean are these signs
of a terrible outcome and
no it sounds like they've retooled this
movie a lot since the last time we heard
about it and so that's what worries me
now because everyone [ __ ] listens to
like Twitter and stuff you know makes
the movie yeah that's true I mean I
totally disagreed though with the voice
over here I was like a horror superhero
movie sounds awesome the MCU like one
thing they figured out was if you want
to increase the longevity and
interestingness of superhero movies
crash them into other genres and so and
of all the current franchises yeah you
have the Hellboy in the works and then
you have spawn in the works which are
supposed to have these horror elements
infused no the spawn trailer was gonna
be funny yeah it's gonna be hilarious
the 80s music yeah you have those in the
works out of all the current franchises
that could actually produce a well made
horror movie it's x-men because x-men
has always been about living in fear you
know yeah and even Logan has it's not
horror but it's like post-apocalyptic
type of vibe that Dredd New Mutants I
think could pull it off so I'm not in
this corner hating on it because I
really hope it'll be good yeah I just
thing is like I strongly disagree with
the whole like oh if it's in any way
serious it must be like a DC EU film
like if your conceit is it's a horror
movie that I get it yeah we all love the
bright burn trailer I've talked a lot
about Aleta on this channel I'm
genuinely III think it's gonna flop I
can't imagine it's gonna do well I get
that I have hopes that it's gonna be
that movie I walk out of going you know
it's a lot better than what a lot of
people expected and I enjoyed it that's
what I feel like that's the best it's
gonna get because as much as people seem
to be really on board for its third
trailer because I love that third
trailer I thought it was the best one
they've has simultaneously though
there's like it looks cool
loos cool but I'm just not gripped by it
it's a it's a hard thing to sell it's
got a beloved source material it's got
its fanbase but nowhere near
the gravity of what ghosts like I feel
like everyone's heard the words ghost in
the shell' oh yeah Michelle and Akira
yeah we bought ubiquitous we've all
heard those words lead up a Tulane July
was like what's this I haven't even
heard of this manga or an anime I have
hopes for it because this was a passion
project for James Cameron and then he
had to hand over the reins because he
decided to do 25 avatar movies I didn't
realize until they said like oh [ __ ] the
last movie Rodriguez did was sin city a
dame to kill for just forever ago yeah
like a five-year gasps especially a guy
who's just like that's the shoot movies
in like a month in a week and you all
the music captain DIY over is been doing
a bunch of El Rey Networks visas were
taking a break to do rough rebel without
a crew the show it excites me that he's
getting to do something this massive but
it is a strange choice yeah yeah because
his movies always have that vibe that
this is a lot of DIY I'm like is he
gonna be able to find a signature style
for this cuz right now it looks cool it
looks passable it looks like you'd be
entertaining
I'm more concerned than it's gonna be a
bad movie as opposed to I'm already sold
it's not gonna make money
I just wanted to at least get a good
Rotten Tomatoes consensus or something
yeah because this thing too is I feel
like Rodriguez weirdly enough can work
really well in an environment where it
isn't just you know he's calling every
shot and there are no rules that he can
do whatever he wants sometimes that
works out but I feel like with
limitations sometimes that can be a good
thing for that's kind of what Sin City 2
showed me was it's like all his sequels
- yeah like really Mario at you Freddy
disappear into so much of what they're
already trying to do yeah you're like
temper this a little bit yeah yeah yeah
those are the ones that I felt compelled
to really discuss here we're discussion
the radish it's like oh yeah one do you
know it'll be interesting to see how
this list pans out book market cuz I am
wondering if we'll get a full sweep or
if yeah there'll be some upsets and
though why not fighting for us
terminator that's the one I'm fighting
cats got it gotta make some money go for
it we felt compelled to talk about the
big blockbusters and cats memories all
alone in the moonlight I reject nation
well what do you think will bomb in 2019
and do you completely disagree with
whatever we have faith in common you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell and more
importantly use our discount code real
rejects Skinit calm link in the
description box for all kinds of good
search they have a whole bunch of more
designs we even got some extra ones over
here and there's some great great great
stuff and it was no code really actually
applying it was getting John and I giddy
it to it was like this is so cool yeah
so do it today thanks guys